So Google Analytics
provides a dashboard where
you can see information about
how people are using your app.
So here in the overview page,
we see how many users.
How many new users we've
had in the past month.
400 not too bad.
Active users, 1,200, so that's
the new users and the previous users.
We can see where in the world
people are using our app, and
we can see what devices
they're using to use the app.
So we can drill down a little bit
more into some of these details.
So, for example, where in the world.
We can, like, really drill down,
we can see how many people, oh,
we have 770 in New Zealand right now.
Oh, one in Madagascar, and then we
can get the actual data for it too.
So, we get the numbers.
And this app that we're using here
was developed by my friend, Ian,
Ian Lake, and you've probably seen him
in the Android fundamentals two course.
We can look into the language
that people are using.
In this case it's predominantly English,
but
we do have Portuguese,
we do have some French users.
So we can drill down more into
the devices that people are using.
So here we see all
the different devices.
And we can see the percentage of
the popularity of the devices.
So, the Galaxy S5 was the most
popular recognized device.
Some of the unrecognized
devices include the emulator,
as well as devices that
Analytics didn't recognize.
You can see the top network operators.
We can even see the screen
resolutions that people used.
The branding.
One of the really cool things I can
show you is the real time data.
You can actually see how many people
are using your app right now.
And actually I have to be honest.
It's not really right now.
It's close to right now.
So it's close to real time.
You can see the top locations
where people are using the app.
So somebody down here in Melbourne
is actually using the app right now.
We have people in Peru using it.
We have people in
the Philippines using it.
We can see what they're
looking at right now.
And of course, you know, one of the main
things you do want to know about your
app is, what parts of
the app are the users using.
You get that through the screens.
So this is not the real time data,
this is overall in the last month.
We can see all the screens,
which screens the users went to, and
a screen is equivalent to an activity.
We see obviously, that the main
screen is where people went the most.
And then you can see, you know,
where else they went in the app.
You can also follow through the flow of
how people navigated through the app.
So, you can see where they started,
where they went to next, and so on.
So, I hope I've convinced you that
Analytics can give you all kinds of
awesome information about how and
where you're apps being used.
And now, I'm going to talk you through
how you can update your apps, so
that you can get all this
awesome kind of information
about how your app is being used.